Film Courage: You said something a moment
ago…”find your tribe.” As someone who
may have felt like an outsider (and I only
say this because I’ve felt like one my entire
life), how do you find your tribe? There’s
a tendency to want a “glob on to,” meaning
you want to fit in with this group because
you think that it’s is going to take you
where you need to go, but it’s not really
a fit. How do you know what your tribe is?
Markus Redmond: You don’t. You just don’t.
You just do what you love, man. It’s all
you can do. All you can do is do what you
want to do. That’s how you find them. Who
those people are gonna be…no idea. But you
just have to do what you do. If you do what
they do, then you’re chasing their tribe
and they’re not necessarily your tribe.
So you’re just chasing after people, like
you know, people pleasing, which is something
I’ve had a problem with the past. You can’t
do that. It’s not good for you and it’s
not good for them. You’re really wasting
everybody’s time when you try to please
everybody, you know I mean? I think you just
have to do what you do. “Do you” as the
kids say. Film Courage: That’s interesting.
Why isn’t it good for them? I can see why
it wouldn’t be good for the individual trying
to be the people pleaser, eventually you’ll
either let them down and they’ll get mad
at you or whatever, but why not for them?
Why does people pleasing hurt the group? Markus:
Why does it hurt the group you’re trying
to please? Well, eventually you can keep it
up. It’s a lie because you’re basically
telling a bunch of people that they can depend
on you to do what they want. It’s not what
you want. You’re gonna crack eventually
and then it’s going to be a waste of their
time and your time. So why do it? Who cares?
You don’t just have to love what you love.
There’s seven billion people on the planet.
I guarantee at least three of them love what
you love. That’s all you really need. You
just need to find three other people like
you, that are good, that like what you like.
And they’re out there. You just have to
do what you do and follow that. The truer
you can be to yourself and what you dig, the
better I think it is for everybody, because
this stuff is hard. It’s not easy to make
movies and all this stuff. You might as well
love it. If you’re gonna do hard stuff,
do hard stuff they’re going to pay you tons
of money for. You know what I mean? Go do
math. Film Courage: Architecture… Markus:Architecture…go
be an architect. That’s hard but you know
they’ll pay a lot of money upfront, it’s
better. I think you have to do this because
you love it, because it’s burning in you.
Film Courage: So let’s take an example of
someone trying to be a people pleaser as an
actor, filmmaker and then another way, to
not engage in people pleasing, but still be
dependable. Markus: So if you’re an actor
or a filmmaker or both you want to be dependable
to people you end up working but you don’t
want to be a people pleaser. Film Courage:
Right, what’s an example of each? Markus:
I think it’s the same thing, just doing
what you love. Because the thing is, if
you love doing something, you’re gonna do
it. People don’t do anything they don’t
want to do and they only do what they have
to do… Film Courage: Well sometimes for
a paycheck…
Markus: But they have to do that. So outside
of that, you don’t do anything you don’t
want to do. If you’re doing something you
don’t want to do, it’s because you have
to do it. Film Courage: How did you catch
yourself being a people pleaser and how did
you change it? Markus: I’m still doing
it. You end up in situations where you feel
like you want to work with people. You feel
like you’re going to gain something out
of that situation. You feel like it’s
going to be mutually beneficial and sometimes
it is. Sometimes it isn’t and sometimes
you get in there and it’s just not working.
You have to be able to say “Okay, well it’s
not working” You have to take ownership
of your own life. You have to take ownership
of what you’re going to do because what
other people are going to do that’s what
they’re going to do. You can only control
what you are going to do. What you are capable
of, what you love. So you might as well
do this thing you love because you know you’re
going to do it and that makes you dependable.
If you’re going to do it because you love
it, you’re going to run into the people
that love the same thing and now it’s mutually
beneficial because you’re dependable because
you both love the same thing. But if I come
to you and I say “Hey, yeah…we’re gonna
do this thing, it’s going to be awesome,
and you’re like ”Yeah, it’s going to
be the best sci-fi horror thing ever and I’m
like yeah! And then I go home and I say, “God,
I hate sci-fi and horror. And I’m like whatever
Karen she know some people and it’s going
to be awesome, so I’m going to keep doing
it. It’s not going to be the best that
I can do, because I don’t really like it.
And you’re going to be like, “Um….I
don’t think this works and this works and
this works” and I’m going to be like it’s
just sci-fi horror, who the hell cares?
You just have to kill people in space. What’s
the big deal? And you’re going to be like,
“I love this.” Now you’ve wasted your
time, their time, everybody’s time, you
know what I mean? So you don’t do it. You
just do the thing you think is awesome.
Not the thing you think is awesome…or
the thing you think other people are going
to find awesome. Do what you think is awesome
and then the people who think that thing is
awesome will show up, too. Everybody thought
Star Wars was just psycho when they first
did it. Look at it now…. Question: What
tips can you add on finding your tribe?